on revient sur le projet de loi
antiterroriste à ottawa le ses 51 mais
cette fois avec le regard de notre
chroniqueur techno matthieu dugal
animateurs de la sphère bonsoir match
alors peut-être qu'il serait bon de
revenir sur ces cinq ans - et voir
justement qu'est ce cas là dedans qui
suscite autant la controverse mais pour
ça il faudrait peut-être s'intéresser à
la lettre publiée par une centaine de
juristes la semaine dernière il est
vraiment très intéressant des journées
des juristes évidemment très alarmiste
et soulignent plusieurs choses à la
suite d'une audience lost en vertu de la
loi à la suite d'une audience à huis
clos dans laquelle seuls les forces de
l'ordre seraient présentes avec un juge
de la cour fédérale le juge pourrait
autoriser toute mesure juste et adaptée
aux circonstances pour réduire les
menaces envers la sécurité du canada et
dans la loi précise on précise que c'est
tout sauf la mort ça commence à faire
pas mal de choses oui autre chose par
exemple et désespère les experts qui
s'inquiètent de la définition beaucoup
trop large qu'on donne à la menace à la
sécurité nationale
est ce que les crs pourrait en vertu de
la loi est filtrée cible est censuré des
groupes écologistes ou autochtone qui se
poseraient par exemple du projet de
pipeline
mais on le sait pas et qu'elle sera
l'imputabilité par exemple le scrs qui
va donc transformé par ce projet de loi
on va avoir plus de pouvoir certains
parlent d'une police parallèle carrément
baisse inquiète bien des gens
l'ex-premier ministre ontarien bob louis
xi et j lui sur le comité de
surveillance des activités de
renseignement de sécurité d'ici on a une
surveillance plus robuste il faut une
surveillance plus grand de ces gens là
qui me seraient et d'ailleurs lors des
révélations snowdon bien des élus aux
états unis dont on parlait qui se sont
réveillés ils étaient sur les comités de
surveillance et on ne les avait même pas
averti de ce contrat mais alors imaginez
ça prend un an ça d' alerte pour
apprendre des choses sur le
fonctionnement du gouvernement ça va mal
et il faut dire aussi que les juristes
soulignent dans leur lettre que le
le comité de surveillance des activités
n'a pas le budget ni le personnel requis
pour faire son travail d'ailleurs faut
rappeler il le souligner que arthur
parker avait été nommé à la tête de cet
organisme la part stephen harper s'en
dit quand même beaucoup il est en prison
exactement panama mais surtout mathieu
que le canada développe en ce moment
même des instruments très sophistiquée
la d'écouté électronique
dans quelques semaines on devrait
assister à l'inauguration du nouveau
centre de la cst du cst le centre de
sécurité dans les télécommunications 1.2
milliard c'est à côté des bureaux du
scrs à glace tu la ontario 2000
personnes vont travailler là des espions
des cryptographe est ce qu'on va faire
de la collection de données de masse le
comment on va le faire encore là on n'y
répond pas et est ce qu'il ya dans le
projet ses 51 des mesures là qui
pourrait un peu freiner les abus mais
c'est justement c'est là où le bât
blesse c'est que il n'ya pas de frein on
ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'on va faire
avec ça et on pourrait peut-être essayer
de résumer ce que tente de nous dire les
gens qui qui pointent vers ces lacunes
lot du projet par une citation d'un
historien britannique est très connue
lord acton historien du 19e siècle
grands champions des libertés
individuelles qui disait ceci le pouvoir
absolu corrompt absolument
alors c'est à méditer belle citation
merci beaucoup match d'hier